My experience here, volunteering in Selamta in Ethiopia,...
...has changed the way I travel.
There is something that happens when you make a connection...
...and you help somebody that actually helps you...
...build your own sense of self.
Selamta creates forever families by uniting orphaned and abandoned children...
...with marginalized women to create new permanent families.
These folks have been through so much...
...and to see them come out on the other side of it changes you.
You can't help but be affected by it,...
...and so every time I come over, I'm constantly inspired.
It's just a beautiful thing to be a part of once you come over.
It's different.
Your life is different afterwards.
These kids and the moms are so resilient.
They have found a way to trust and  love in spite of it all.
I think I came to Selamta thinking that I would help the  families and help the kids...
...and what has really changed is that they have helped me.